some very very unusual and interesting
pictures that did very well I'm on
Instagram now and a lot of our viewers
are really engaging on there and i I'm
I'm actually growing a following which
seems to be very very interested in the
strange antics that I sometimes get up
to during the weekend up first picture
i'm going to show you that did really
really well over the last week on the
way into the studio i took a picture of
myself just stuck in traffic and uh I I
don't know why the picture was so
fascinating but people really really
liked it and a lot of people asking if I
have a right hand drive vehicle because
the way that the front camera on my
phone works it basically is creating a a
flipped or mirror image so it does look
like I'm sitting in the right seat in
the passenger seat of a car uh but I'm
not I'm actually sitting in the driver's
seat but because it's a it's a reversed
image I wish I understood more about why
the selfie cameras work in this way but
they do and uh it was a very very
traumatic day that the show was almost
late because the traffic was so bad in
Boston and finally and a few people
emailing me about this uh on monday i
shaved finally over the weekend and i
put up a picture of that and uh I uh I
did not expect it to be that big of a
deal but i have had scruff for a for
quite a long time now and people say i
look even younger with the shaved face
and you know what i'm actually
completely fine with that because at
this point i'm not feeling as young as I
used to in terms of you know the whole
oh uh this is one of the younger hosts
on free speech TV blah blah blah I don't
know that any of that stuff is true
anymore so anything I can do to get
emails from people saying I look even
younger is really really great but I
want to warn everybody we are going on
show vacation very very soon my policy
is I do not take shaving supplies with
me on vacations period so there is going
to be significant growth when uh when I
return and by significant I mean there
will be a shadow that might be
noticeable in high definition as we film
the show remember you can follow me on
Instagram
I am on instagram at david dot Pakman
also instagram.com slash david pakman
and there is a membership discount code
that I list on Instagram only so if
you're looking for a discount on
membership you can find it if you follow
me on Instagram